Glenn's go fishing right here we want to
get camera into the water you can't
monitor what this camera sees but
hopefully we'll comes out
Isis shaking I feel the vibration yeah
we're gonna go ahead and I'm going to
step back one of the main concerns that
we have is all being clustered up in the
same area ice can tend to split and
fracture if similar to go in got throw
wrote a column out
unfortunately for Glenn and my priority
is my hammer guys it's a little pin I
can feel it in my feet the crack of my
face it can all just cave-in at once
actually that's holding this up awesome
there you go so we get underwater shots
this is what happens
when the hardest things about getting
put into bandy on a dogsled is keeping
up with them to get the shot so the
river is barely frozen enough and pretty
sketchy here lots of cracking and Isak
breaking under you're very scary
situation on a river that's only been
frozen for less than 36 hours so to
support the way the snow machines we
stay on the banks it's a safe way to
travel around here
start working
and I had
we're up the hill God is done